okay welcome everyone welcome to our
Thursday conference and we it's good to
see a few of the bioinformatics folks
here we have a somewhat clinically
oriented talk today but that's fine and
I'm pleased to introduce someone who
many years ago sat in this room as a
student dr. J Eisenberg is actually an
alumnus of our program
he was a pediatric pulmonologist I guess
I guess I can violate hip about my
daughter actually saw him as a patient
when she was it was exit before HIPPA he
was pediatric pulmonologist here at OHSU
and like a number of you got the
informatics bug and made a complete he
did our master's program fact you know
he did it a while ago because his degree
is actually called medical informatics
back before we changed it to biomedical
informatics and anyways he then had a
very successful career he worked for
many years for Cerner actually it might
be interesting to hear what he thinks
about what's happening with Cerner now
maybe he'll talk about that all the new
contracts and so forth the new big
contracts that Cerner has and then I
think he got tired of traveling so he
came back took a job with Southwest
Washington yeah I'll go through a little
bit of that together ok I'll let him
tell the whole story
he's also been a member of our affiliate
faculty so he has interacted with the
program in in many ways he's a physician
by training went to medical school
Baylor College College of Medicine I
guess and trained in pediatrics and then
pulmonary medicine so I will let him
fill in all the details thank you thank
you Bill hello just a question who is
whose boots more on the applied clinical
side and who's more on the you know
other the scientific side even though
research say yeah I just just to just
kind of curious who is clinical okay
okay well those of you who are on I'm
happy to have you here and actually I
felt a bit intimidated coming here and
talking about this because I'm going to
talk about a few things that I learned
in the program but I am NOT going to
tell you other than how important they
are I mean you have people who are
really experts in some of these areas so
my my goal is just to tell you about
kind of how I ended up where I am and
what physician or clinical informatics
ist's or CM iOS or do and there's a lot
of different titles now there's CMIO and
there's chief health information officer
and chief health informatics officer and
wherever you work in wherever you are
whatever happens today won't be the same
tomorrow and dan can attest to that as
we go through changes in our governance
which I'm going to talk about as well so
and I do have an MMI which can't get
anymore when I started the program that
wasn't even available it was only an MS
in 1997 so I wasn't actually sure what I
was going to do but ended up with the
MMI so I'm going to talk about the items
in the box a little bit
I'm not going to talk about the items
that are at the bottom not that they're
not important but I just didn't feel
like it was enough time and I wanted to
talk about a couple of those other
things but I'm gonna be staying around
and we can certainly go ahead and
freeform this as well people if any of
you have questions about some of those
other areas happy to talk about it
dan and I you've got about I don't know
25 40 years of combined experience doing
this so yeah so I had to write some
questions for this and these objectives
sort of point to those it's not they're
not hard they're just that was that what
I had to do so I want to talk a little
bit about the usual competencies and
requirements reasons to have governance
in a in a healthcare organization or
really any other organization no with
the organizational levels that are
important there's one slide on
organizational behavior because I could
not do Joe Nash any justice in that area
and I'll talk about my experience in
that class and why I think it's so
important and then finally just a little
bit on change management and adoption so
bill went through some of this I
practiced Pete's pulmonary here and then
I was involved in helping with decision
making about some information systems at
the time this was over early 90s so
stand alone this or that report you know
results review system which is doesn't
make this much anymore as you know that
kind of thing I got interested actually
went to Bill came to Bill and said so
I'm interested what do I do and he goes
both take my class and I took it I go I
liked it what do I doing he goes take
another class and I did I go now when he
goes you have to apply the program so I
did and just sort of pecked away at it
so I was here until 2000 and I left I
had an opportunity to do something else
which ended up being seven and a half
years with Cerner corporation so big EHR
company that was a cultural change for
me it was quite a different kind of
culture and then
I had an opportunity to become the CMIO
over what was called Southwest
Washington Medical Center in Vancouver
and I had always lived here in fact my
house used to be until I sold it June
was up the hill down for him on a mile
and down about two blocks so it was
close by and so I stopped weekly travel
and started commuting which I'd never
done much of Portland and that became
that became interesting as you know and
then I as part of Southwest Washington
Medical Center they started talking to
peace health about an affiliation and
that happened so they're nonprofits they
affiliate they don't acquire that was
the term so we became part of peace
health and I stayed at Southwest until
2003 at which time I took this position
which didn't really exist largely to
work on the implementation of the system
my electronic health record which is
epic our ambulatory clinics had already
started that but they need it they
needed a CMIO for that so I was kind of
in the right place at the right time and
the opportunity was there and it was a
position that was posted and I applied
and there I was so peace health I'll
show you another slide is it's kind of a
medium-sized Health System
there are really big health systems
around and then there are smaller so
there are I'll show you a map but
there's about 16,000 employees so so
UPMC had one about 60,000 so bigger
system and they're you know they're big
and small medium there are ten hospitals
and I'll show you how there they're
spread out because it's kind of
important five or critical access
hospitals critical access hospitals if
you don't know are subsidized hospitals
that can have a maximum of 25 beds that
serve rural communities that need
and there's an employed medical group
about a thousand providers so there are
three networks of care that are really
geographically quite distinct which
makes covering them a challenge so so my
colleague at Legacy Amy Chow montón
who's the CMIO
can get in her car if she needs to meet
one group of people at one Hospital and
then go to the next I can't do that
so the northwest I'll start at the top
northwest network includes those four
facilities Ketchikan if you haven't been
up there it's kind of the first town in
Alaska it's not it's got about 8,000
9,000 people and it sits on a big island
up there and you only way to get there
is to take a boat take a plane or swim
so I take a plane it's about an hour and
a half from Seattle it's got a critical
access hospital a very busy high acuity
critical access hospital because you
can't put someone in an ambulance and
take them down the road to the big
Medical Center okay there are three
facilities here one is a large hospital
in Bellingham there's two small or
hospitals one in Friday Harbor which is
in the San Juan Islands and one down in
sedro-woolley which is 25 miles south
Hospital at Friday Harbor it's a medical
center very low acuity the average
inpatient daily census is one they don't
really keep very ill patients so anyone
who's mildly ill it's flown or taken by
boat over to one of the other hospitals
or flown to Seattle two hospitals what
we call the Columbia Network one in
Longview and one over in Vancouver
they're both larger hospitals and then
there's four down in in Oregon Eugene
Springfield Cottage Grove in Florence so
that just gives you a sense of the
spread of it there are no two health
systems in this kind
that are all like so this is just the
way peace health is set up so first
thing I want to talk about is the
competencies and this may be incomplete
but I went through and I kind of looked
at the competencies that a Mia had list
this is paraphrase from a Mia and then I
looked at the clinical informatics board
competencies and try to put them in in
sort of different boxes and they're
things like the documentation and CPOE
aren't competencies but they take a lot
of understanding and effort in in a big
healthcare system I just wanted to call
those out but change management adoption
strategy governance budgeting and
resources program project management all
the things on here I am involved with or
I lead or co-lead or I go to meetings
and discussions and learn because I
don't I'm not an expert in many of these
areas other CMIO that I've met over the
years have areas of expertise there that
are different so there are there I have
colleagues around the country who are
really much more are better versed about
reporting and analytics they can write
sequel and go in and do that I can't
quite do that but I kind of know what
needs to be done and I can sit with a
reporting analyst and and quickly define
what I need although the boards that I
took have one question it has had four
sequel queries we had to say which one
was correct so you do have to understand
the logic in the approach but I'm not on
that I'm not that deep into that a lot
of the the billing and revenue cycle
parts of things I'm also not I you know
or
not quite I'm not quite an expert in but
our revenue cycle team is involved with
almost every discussion that we have
because there isn't anything almost
there's almost nothing you do in
electronic health record or changing a
workflow or adding content that won't
affect revenue and they're very
sensitive to that
so things that don't seem to affect
revenue do and I learn new things every
day so that's that's an area and then
these other areas are as you can see I
put this one here because this normally
is not a core competency at least of
many chief medical information officers
or equivalent I have many colleagues who
know this stuff they came up on more of
a technical side and are really quite
good I have a couple of friends who were
CMIO Zorn and are now CIOs who are
physicians so they obviously have much
more expertise in this area but they
don't really manage they manage the
budget and the resources and they depend
on really smart people to help with that
no one's ever gonna come to me and say
how many servers you want me to order I
know what those aren't them so that's
sort of the the area of competency and
those of you in clinical areas will
probably have a couple of areas that you
start with his expertise and depending
on where your career goes you tend to
learn things so when I left my clinical
practice I haven't seen a patient 17
years which was a big cultural change I
just renewed my license I still actually
have one in Oregon but I don't see
patients I started working with groups
of providers and nurses in areas that I
had no knowledge about I didn't know an
see geologists workflow or I didn't know
what an IDI physician provider did with
a patient with XY and Z I sort of did
because I used to receive those but I
ended up learning the gory details of
many of those workflows and their needs
both in the clinical areas and in the
non clinical areas so lab and pharmacy
and a lot of those areas you just learn
and you know over the years it's become
I mean I found that that it's been it's
been it's positive it's been a positive
growth area for me don't have you know
my clinical expertise in the area that I
used to have but I can pretty much go to
a meeting at any Hospital with any group
of providers or nurses and talk the talk
and understand what they're doing at
least enough to be competent and not be
considered an outsider so and stop you
here any questions on heavy this stuff
this is taken from some job descriptions
that I looked at so instead of the
competencies these are sort of more
requirements and qualifications I just
wanted to do the kind of see and I try
to group them in some logical areas the
top one is kind of a key one lead
planning and implementation but all the
items about workflow and knowledge of
informatics trends and engaging wide
areas of providers and at P selphie call
people caregivers understand way people
are and what how they're thinking and
understand you're going to go into
meetings that are going to be hostile or
that you're gonna have to deliver
information that the audience isn't
gonna want to hear but there are ways to
do that by acknowledging it and saying
how can I work how can we or I work with
you all on what we have to do so if
there's a new regulation and providers
or nurses have to do something they
don't want to do but they have to do it
you have to figure out a way to get that
done so that's just an example there um
privacy security HIPPA personal health
information population health all of
these areas are pretty common in a in a
job description and qualifications and
then these are qualifications so and and
this is very narrow so for a chief
medical information officer chief health
information officer or a physician in
fermat assists now this could be a nurse
informaticists - there is a degree
requirement there's experience and it
kind of depends on on the position and
the health and the employer if you will
so for my position which I'm retiring
from in July the I think it says five to
ten years is what we're asking so I get
a phone call from someone who's got four
and a half years and they're worried
should I apply and it's those are the
kind of things that are negotiable but
you got to have depending on where you
want to end up going you got to have
some experience and even sort of an
entry position like a full-time position
informatics is somewhere your experience
if I mean you've got practice experience
and you're going to have informatics
experience that's fine and then people
that's how I think both then and I got
experience it was on the job and then
board certification in a primary
specialty for some organizations as
important so Pediatrics internal
medicine something
and then right now most of the
descriptions are preferred for clinical
informatics so those of you may who are
going there no you have to have this in
order to be eligible for this right bill
so and that's sort of the qualifications
and descriptions any questions about
that okay so I'm going to talk a little
bit about governance we've only spent
four hours already today on governance
yes we've been on a few calls
so simply stated in my mind governance
is the ability to provide you the
ability to formally say no so I joke and
I set this little string here and if you
pull the string
no no so and but no in a nice way no in
a way that lets an idea be discussed and
vetted and evaluate it and if it's not
the right idea it doesn't go anywhere
I'll talk a little bit more about that
so the purpose is to have some
consistency in confidence so people in
your organization know where to go and
what to do and who to ask so right now
when we were when we went up with epic
at our in our hospitals which we did
geographically and I'll show you a
little timeline there was thousands of
new decisions that needed to be made
because we were pulling the rug out from
everyone's workflow using a couple of
different EMRs in many different ways at
that the hospitals and we we put in you
know a system where here are a group of
decisions here's the people we need at
the table please come if you're not
there the decision will be made without
you and that happens a lot and people
come back and say I wasn't there
and the answers that's correct but you
were invited
sometimes it's that's what happens so
you need a strategy a clinical a
clinical governance strategy a data
governance strategy which is slightly
different and then an IT strategy which
more is your technology in your
infrastructure and some of that now
light of these overlap but that's sort
of where you go so if you map I will to
see this but you want to go from K chaos
to some sort of structure that your
constituents your stakeholders know is
there and know what to do and know how
to get something in the queue to be
discussed and it's really important and
it's really hard it's a big cultural
change so we'll talk about that a little
bit organizational behavior so you
really want your governance to be
democratic you don't want it to be
tribal and you don't want it to be
authoritarian I pulled this out of a
little article I saw and and I'm so
democratic and this is his referenced I
found it here Democratic means that
don't govern try not to govern what
doesn't need governance there's some
things that need to be left alone and
then there's other things that need
governance and so and I'll talk about
that I think that's on the next slide
but you need to figure out what you
spend a lot of time on an effort and
what don't you spend a lot of time on an
effort and you know governance I mean
here a lot of governance that's outside
of this area there's facilities
governance you know you need facility
work done and there's this much money
and there's this much time so what gets
done for a second third or fourth and
what doesn't get done it's kind of the
same kind of thing
the quality is has to
do with the the validity and the
timeliness and the completeness of what
is being governed so you want things to
get into a queue and be addressed in a
timely manner and the results are
communicated back the timeliness is hard
and the communication is really hard
especially in a large organization so
what you want governance to do also is
to consider access which is basic sort
of a security tenant you know open
access means no security total security
means no access you got to have a point
at which access to the you know clinical
content or the data is it's accessible
but organizationally its protected so
you have to have that in place literacy
means that people are using the the
information or the data know what it
means and know how to use it so you may
have reporting tools we had a call this
morning about this so we have to be able
to working with our chief medical
officers on a couple of reports and what
we're trying to do is come up with a way
that they can access things relatively
easy and and efficiently they're gonna
read them it's gonna require some
training just as an example so content
governance the first thing you need to
do is decide on what systems you're
going to use to collect what you're
trying to govern I mean it's as simple
as an electronic health record or a is
it on a pile of paper you can't do any
of the analysis until that that part is
taken care of and then analytics is just
basically a prioritization process
you've got a lot you've got a lot of
data and then to me the reporting is fun
is there okay so I've got a report
and then the analysis of that frequently
so the reporting tends to be a little
more IT but not always and the analysis
is a little more on the end-user
stakeholder side but it's a continuum
and finally standards local standards
I'll give you an example if you have
three hospitals and they were number
their rooms differently and call their
floor something differently and you put
in an electronic health record you got a
standardized the naming of the floors in
the rooms it's a local standard okay and
it's hard for people who are one place
to change because they know that that
room down there is room 14 B and we're
changing it industry standards you're
learning all about icd-10 llowing Icom
so this is kind of a high-level view of
the governance that we're working on and
it's just it starts with a request an
idea it gets created you have to track
these somehow you have to have a
tracking system so they get tracked
operational owners discuss it if they
think it's a good idea if they don't
think it's a good idea it goes in
trashcan if you will they do think it's
a good idea we have a review process
we're putting a review process to make
sure that all the stakeholders who need
to participate in the decision have and
the level of effort if the review
process says up the pharmacists need to
take a look at this and needs to go back
for review so you don't want it to get
here and then someone to say like what
medication reconciliation is one example
where our nurses can't discharge a
patient until that process is complete
so if we change the process for the
providers and the pharmacist and the
nurses aren't there you you hear about
it
so you need to make sure everyone's
involved and then in our right now level
of effort there's actually kind of two
bifurcation points for level of efforts
I put a bread box there so I say it's
either smaller than or bedrocks bigger
than a bread box or a bakery so what
we're trying to do is get any of these
small requests to just get done they
don't need to go up
they don't need resources they don't
need money they just need to get them
anything that is bigger than probably
ten hours that's analysts and
informatics is work needs to go into a
queue where a group of operational
owners and me and my equivalent it
appears will look at all of these and
prioritize them for funding or they're
really big and they need to go to the
executive team so if it's a project
that's ten thousand hours and a million
dollars it's going to go up to that
group to make a decision okay and you
can't always tell when you get started
how big things are some things seem big
and they're not something seems small in
they're huge so any questions about this
and there's a million different ways to
do this maybe a million anyway yes
that's a great question so you you have
a group of resources that and I'll focus
on the informatics ist's in the analyst
now an organization the analysts are
with our IT group but we work very
closely so that group works this many
hours and part of their time is is
allocated to address things like what we
call break fix right stuff has to be
fixed there's other things compliance
and regulatory things that happen that
need to happen so they have a certain
amount of time for that
we have upgrades and maintenance so much
time for that
then the two other areas are
optimization which is a lot of what this
fits into and strategic areas where the
organization has something that needs to
be done because of its strategic or part
of the strategic plan so the hard part
is getting all that done with that many
resources and if so if it gets here and
it can be resourced that's fine if it
can't it needs to go for executive
review and if it needs extra resources
and they approve it they have to fund it
but what doesn't work is constantly
going saying I need more people to do
this and the other thing it doesn't work
well like that so it's a good question
so one slide so and just a little story
so when I took organizational behavior
from Joan I had no idea why that class
was part of this curriculum I just it
was required
right so I did it other than bills it's
the best class I took so anyway it was
when I got done with it I realized how
important it was and how well it was
taught so all I want to want to tell you
is that the the the biggest challenge
are the people challenges and working
with an organization so Joan said once
that you know but did she say
organizational culture is social what
you call it social Malou organizational
glue I can't remember it's been a while
and that's stuck and it's kind of the
things that that you know are kind of
under the mission and vision and that
your leadership will will continually
reinforce but there are I there are
distinct organizational
behavioral differences from organization
to organization and I really saw that a
lot back in my Cerner days when I was
working with three or four at a time and
over this the eight years I probably
worked with 25 or 30 there were quite a
few differences so you don't get
anything done if you don't understand
that the organization has this this
culture and the only other the only
thing I wanted to mention is and this is
from the organizational behavior
literature so and when I was reviewing
it the one thing I took away is that
these are all important you know
research why someone may have more of a
interest in one area but everything here
is important so just that's my only
comment about organizational behavior so
I want to talk a little bit now about
change management change management and
adoption and how to equip and get your
organization prepared for the changes
that are coming and this is a constant
this never goes away but for something
like a large EMR implementation or large
projects like that it's enormous
so we had a group of change management
professionals working with us through
the the four plus years of the our at
least our Hospital implementation and
I'll show you a little bit of the tools
that we used with them but in the kind
of the diagrams our joke follow a couple
of the change management models you know
someone hears about something then they
scratch their head and then most people
want to go hide and they don't want me
to they don't want to hear about it
because it's not going to affect them
but it does and then when they realize
that it will they people get nervous
terrified what you really want to end up
with is someone who feels successful and
having made the change in their they're
using they've adopted the change and
they're using perhaps it's an you know
an electronic health record - they're
becoming experts if you will and then
you get to a point where if you say
you're going to change or taking that
away and putting in another one and they
say no then you know you've been
successful because then they've made
that change there are different change
management models and I just listed four
of them they're add cars a very common
one and for those of you who have taken
the classes and if you're taking the
boards these were on there I do remember
so study those and know the differences
things like that okay so this is we use
this as a kind of curve because it was
medically appropriate and so you you go
those are the add car areas so awareness
desire knowledge ability reinforce and
typically people go through this sort of
like I said denial and then frustration
and then despair and finally acceptance
and this takes a long time and our last
group of hospitals went live October a
year ago and I would say that that last
group of hospitals I'm not sure a lot of
them are still kind of it's not a lot of
the folks are still here there are some
folks that are there culturally that
group was the most dug into the old way
and they continue to want to do it the
old way we had a call yesterday where
one old way was brought up is that was
great and it actually wasn't but we
didn't argue about that so that's sort
of the the typical change and adoption
curve that you see so this is an excerpt
both horizontally and vertically of a
time line that we did and it doesn't go
back to phase one and two it starts at
phase three and typically things are
broken up by calendar years or fiscal
years and phases and things like that
the most important thing on this is that
change and adoption started it back way
back here and goes through the whole a
lot of these other areas don't so system
build and testing and training and all
the work that goes into that and
workflow standardization and even post
go live some of these things continue to
cycle on and off but that never changes
and I can tell you it still doesn't has
not changed so that's the takeaway from
this and just to give you a little bit
of an idea this is actually accurate the
way we did so we went live in the three
different networks and the first one we
did and then we weighed it nine months
before the second one because the first
ones the hardest and there's a lot more
that has to be fixed and then the second
one we did and there's five months
between that in here and I think in
retrospect we've probably needed more
than five months although you would
think ah by the second or third one
you're you're humming we were better but
I still think we needed a little more
time and if you talk to like Todd guns
Berger was the CMIO for the big
Providence system and when they went to
epic and start it they did one and
waited a year before the second and
there was a lot of delay and then they
started they had this team and they
could get it get a you know a whole
group of their hospitals up and running
in a much more efficient quick way but
it takes a while so this is
just to impress you of all the work that
these are going to change management and
all of the different kinds of events and
you need a team of people so so I
honestly lor you know I started learning
more about the the practical aspects of
this when I was with Cerner but then
being a consultant is a little different
than being on the on the side where
you're living it as well so I and my
team and colleagues we participated in
many of these meetings and discussions
that were part of the planning or the
actual work that was being done and then
this is just an excerpt from a tool that
the team used because it's hard to know
how ready people are until you ask them
so it's really important to do some
assessment and find out where there is
are so we used heat maps if you've seen
heat maps they're kind of you know the
the areas of heat or there is that
needed attention and you don't know that
until you've kind of assessed that so
and you almost all know CPOE this is an
old slide and actually I gave a talk
last month in University of British
Columbia because a friend of mine who's
a physician who now lives in Victoria
teaches an undergraduate informatics
class there's pretty interesting is 115
students and he asked me to come give a
talk so this was part of that so you all
know what CPOE as you know don't look at
the definition they didn't know so and I
was trying to explain how when you
automate clinical processes how profound
things can be so that is a list of paper
orders and some of us can interpret that
right but you know that's dangerous so
it's just the way it is so I'm just
showing you to sort of standard CPOE
orders here one
which shows the same order in a patient
who's who's allergic so the you know the
next slide talks about decision support
this provides early decision support and
I could still write this order and I'm
gonna get another alert and I can
override that alert and the order can go
to pharmacy in nursing and hopefully
someone's gonna look and say that this
is really serious you know he didn't pay
attention and that happens a lot so so
the changes are you know before and
after most of you know this so who
changes when you do something like
electronic orders or go to electronic
documentation
pretty much everyone anyone who writes
or execute orders changes so there's not
a lot of people that ride orders doctors
nurses a few other people but the rest
of the organization X execute orders
because care isn't delivered until
orders are written so the recipients of
those orders change because the orders
are given to them in a different time
it's almost instantaneous they're they
don't look the same the transmittal of
those orders they may go to three or
four places the orders when they're
executed get billed that's how the
hospital bills for its services so it's
really important and then orders are
faster to execute you can put real-time
decision support in place like I showed
you but if you ask a doctor who used to
write paper order they're gonna tell you
this takes longer and the answer is yes
it does I would rather have you take an
extra thirty seconds doctor doing this
then scribbling that stuff that you used
to do and the studies back and you know
that you probably have have read or
heard about mostly done in the 1990s and
early 2000s that looked at aspects of
CPOE sure
they're peer-reviewed so you can bring
peer-reviewed articles to the naysayers
and in our in our organization we had
very good adoption to see Pierre
community there's only one residency
program at Southwest it's a family
medicine there's 24 residents so it's
not an academic center where the
residents are writing orders these are
community dachshund employed and we had
very good uptake of CPE he really was
not a challenge other than providing
that support and then I think fine I'm
going to talk a little bit about
clinical workflows we're doing good on
time so workflow is just a process
involving a series of tasks and I think
an experienced infirm ancestor CMI are
going to tell you ok their system design
and there's content all this but it's
sort of like real estate its workflow
workflow workflow and what you do is
you're changing workflows and to me a
lot of workflow that people perform are
things that they've you know any of
you've taken care of patients you have a
series of things that you do so you
don't forget no error of omission and
that you do the right thing and when you
impose a change
you pull that workflow rug out from
under someone and you provide them a
tool that you think is efficient and
lets them do the work but they have to
rethink it from the beginning
and those in our generation have done it
for longer and they're they don't change
this is easily the young hospitalists
when we have a downtime hate it they
have no idea how to write paper orders
the old Doc's love it it's pretty
interesting so you really upset the
workflow so there's a whole lot of
workflows we I think defined about
between nine hundred and a thousand and
that's not complete when we did this
at peace healthy clinical informatics
team zones the workflows I'm going to
just show you two that you might think
are simple just to show you the amount
of thought that has to go into it one is
out patient blood product ordering so I
have a patient that I'm following in the
clinic and there they have chronic
anemia and they come in in they're not
acutely oh but I need to send them to
the infusion center for a unit of packed
red blood cells something like that so
when when a physician writes an order
they magic happens I think a lot of what
actually happens is completely opaque to
most providers they don't know who gets
the order they don't know all the
details of how it happens or what has to
happen but they're not happy if the
orders not execute it they're not happy
if they don't get the results which is
fair enough
right so don't worry about the details
because they're hard to read and if you
get the slides you can look at it this
is a this is blood I've got two of these
this is just ordering this is the
provider seeing the patient and
determining that they need a blood they
need a blood product so they sign the
order and they're done that's here's the
magic so the order go who's going to
draw the the patient needs some baseline
labs who's going to draw if it goes to
the lab which lab do they go to if they
go to the infusion center it gets
assigned to an nurse these are both
independent workflows here I won't get
into so the patient gets drawn the blood
bank gets the specimen and then the
blood bank goes through and blood banks
are very rigid in their process for good
reason so they go through a process of
take
the specimen and getting the blood
product ready for the the patient when
the patient arrives in the infusion
center patient arrives and then here is
the administration process that and if
patient gets registered which I don't
even think I have up here and then
there's an infusion process and there's
a this is just a checklist basically
it's just shown in a flow diagram where
each of these steps has to happen and if
one step doesn't happen the rest of it
falls apart which for when you implement
an integrated electronic health record
those previous steps are the basis for
things that ensue they have to be done a
nurse for example can't receive a
patient
wherever that patient is going to if
they don't have orders I mean it's just
they can't so it all has to happen so I
just wanted to give you a sense of the
complexity and the detail that has to
happen here so when and finally okay
finally that one of the things I wanted
to say about this is when we get go back
to governance and we get requests one of
the things that's determined is you know
this isn't broke and they're just not
following the workflow so it's a
training and workflow issue we're no
we're not going to redesign this we're
not adding that if if you follow these
steps
everything will ensue so that's sort of
it so I those are the areas I wanted to
talk to you about these I didn't have
any particular anything to say but happy
to answer questions and or get two
different opinions from dan and I
however you don't want to
any questions yeah that was great thank
you
sure I wonder if you're on the receiving
end I'm on the receiving end
I think I'm on fishin burnout you did a
lot of study and the interesting thing
like the study that you know an ER doc
does mm clicks in a day
what kind of post go live analysis are
you doing maybe collecting metadata to
look at if doctor you know spending
pajama times oh you know how many hours
are they charting afterwards how long or
each of these steps taking and maybe
what effects it would have on on things
like turnover and absenteeism or other
other measurable outcomes so great
question
so burnout the leading one of the
leading contributors to burnout is
electronic health records that's it's
not the only but it's one of them it's
sometimes it's sort of that you know the
last straw so we are we have and we are
and we will all kind of get into that so
we can look at items there are physician
efficiency profiles that run in the
background but for ambulatory physicians
only at this point epic just released it
for inpatient where you can actually
look at what area of the electronic
health record they're looking in at the
encounter level and then it for the day
so they're spending you know 10% of
their time in there in basket and X
percent of their time here and then you
can also look at the time of day that
they're doing it so what the Medical
Group has done is identifying physicians
other and other providers who are
spending too much time in areas
they shouldn't be no words there
whatever the reason is sometimes it's
just resupport retraining and then also
looking at those who have a big blip
after you know in the evenings and so
that's being addressed we haven't
started that for impatient and it's a
little bit different because ambulatory
providers and Ettore encounters are just
that patient comes in a scene series of
things are done in the encounter is
closed can't do that for an impatient
because you it's not encountering
there's multiple providers so you can't
look at it at the provider it'll excuse
man encounter level other thing we just
did is working with an organization
called class klas on a project that
they're looking at it's it's good
they're calling the arch project now but
see it's it's e EMR provider efficiency
and they have a survey that about 40
organizations have done now I think
they're going up to 60 we sent out we
just got the results so we're looking at
those areas where we the providers
dinged us if you will comparing those
results to what other organizations are
saying and Danna I've talked a little
bit about this I want to bring that
those data to our executive team as
here's it we you know our strategic plan
our big strategic plan has has provider
and caregiver experience in it and if we
can focus on a couple of areas where
providers this case the providers are
telling us we're not doing well and it's
interesting there's some areas that we
didn't get terribly good ratings and no
one does
you benchmark you're sort of in the yeah
and then there's other that are really
quite distinct that there are some
organizations that do really well in
some areas and
don't so what I want to do is pick out a
few where we're not doing well and we
can and yeah you want hope with it okay
I I wanted to ask you a question about
how you manage or encourage innovation
within your system you know I certainly
recognized that in a big system like
this there are quality things that
you're trying to always catch up on and
there are metrics that you that are
established that you want to try to make
sure you're doing as well as you can on
but then there's also how do we try to
get ahead of this and how do we foster
new and innovative ideas within our
system and and I wonder you know from
your standpoint how do you deal with
that kind of a strategy not well and
actually Dan's experience was more
mature coming from a more mature
organization I think that's for maybe do
you think you could address how you did
that at UPMC because I'll be honest with
you it's a frustrating area because
there are areas where we've had
providers and other care givers who have
great ideas and we don't really have a
way to take that and support them it's
maybe if you wouldn't mind sure sure so
my name is Dan Martin and I came from
the University of Pittsburgh Medical
Center where I was CMIO for 15 plus
years and upmc's unique in that it is
both a health system it's an insurance
product group of physicians there's
3,500 employ Doc's and a 6000 on medical
staff but we saw the need for innovation
particularly around health IT a while
ago and we started to encourage that
both of the clinical staff of the
scientific staff associate with the
University of Pittsburgh and in every
commercial product we dealt with so when
we bought Cerner which was in 1990
eight we said we want a piece of the
action we became the thirteenth largest
stakeholder and Cerner corporation
helped them influence their product line
Judy Faulkner didn't offer the same deal
so we have Cerner inpatient at UPMC
presently an epic in ambulatory setting
so which led to another opportunity to
innovate and we then bought investigated
interoperability companies back in 405
something like that and we we we
partnered with bought a company out of
Tel Aviv it was called DB motion if
anybody remembers that company we
brought their US headquarters who
brought their headquarters to Pittsburgh
innovated with them and then ultimately
sold it to all scripts about five years
after we owned it and made a significant
amount of money we I'll get Paul Chang
credit who was a radiologist he he
developed something called DTS Dai name
transfer syntax so that you can actually
appreciate PACs images better than GE or
Fuji or Philips was doing at the time we
developed that in-house we sold it to
Philips for two hundred and eighty
million dollars about a decade ago and
so that has led to something called the
Technology Development Center now it's
been renamed I've been gone from EMC for
about three years called UPMC
enterprises which basically you saw
health catalyst slide up there BPM sees
heavy investor owner and health
enterprises there's a company called
Evelyn health which is similar to XG in
that they do population health
understanding and that's a joint
partnership between the advisory board
and UPMC so to answer your question if
you want to do something like that
you better say that you want to do it
you better have the resources and the
understanding that if we're going to
take great ideas
it goes back actually into that plan and
what happens is it kicks out and says
this is a great idea it's not going to
be solved by the EMR not going to be
solved by this vendor product maybe we
need to do some investigation and that
investigation
a lot of those either independent
projects being funded or partnering with
other vendors I think this and and the
markets ripe with those other vendors I
think Amazon and Google and others are
probably
is that is that the same Paul Chang
whose father accused him of destroying
radiology rounds because because his
because back in our day when we used to
go look at x-rays our only option was to
walk down to the radiology department
and put the film's up under view boxes
and then Paul Chang whose father was a
radiologist to it Bob Wachter tells this
story some of you know Bob walked
through the author of the digital doctor
he it's in the book and I've heard him
talk about it that you know his father
was a radiologist and said you destroyed
because the the physicians and the warts
don't need to go down to radiology
anymore because they can look at it on
that device yeah yeah I can have a one
of the discussions I had up at UBC with
them was what a PAC system does and one
of the things was it changes the dynamic
everyone would go down and look at films
and you don't do that anymore then there
was a social aspect to that that got
lost as we're learning this week and in
other realms technology has its
drawbacks well I I really want to thank
Jay for coming and Dan for adding some
perspective and thank you
[Applause]